trouver son sport son activité
culturelle ou s'engager pour une cause
un casse tête pour les visiteurs des
forums d'associations à magny les
hameaux 90 structures sont actives près
de 250 bénévoles étaient présents pour
animer cet événement ça permet de
d'avoir de la visibilité
mine de rien
c'est important aussi que les nouveaux
les nouvelles personnes qui arrivent
donc sur mannino sachent qu'il ya du
basket à côté du sport les associations
caritatives présentent leur mission
c'est le cas de la marche à suivre qui
organise des marots tous les dimanches à
mon objectif cette foire trade
association de manière transversale
j'ai pris des contacts avec
l'association vestiaire qui elle
justement travailler sur la récupération
de vêtements pour pouvoir les
redistribuer aux personnes qui en ont
besoin donc du coup va ça permettrait de
créer comme comme cet exemple à des
collaborations c'est très intéressant la
vie associative un enjeu politique
majeur pour les communes et quelques
difficultés sur le renouvellement des
bénévoles qu'on essaie d'accompagner au
mieux en proposant des formations on
travaille sur une école du bénévolat
pour essayer de former les nouvelles
générations bénévolat mais plus maman a
plutôt dynamique et qu' on essaie
d'accompagner son dynamisme
c'est important parce que ça permet
aussi aux guyancourt toit de pouvoir se
rencontrer du pouvoir participer à une
association et ne pas être isolé c'est
le vivre ensemble c'est pour ça
effectivement c'est quelque chose auquel
on tient énormément nous la municipalité
de favoriser la création d'associations
ou la cua la pérennité de certaines des
associations en soutien en 2018 est
municipalité de guyancourt consacre près
de 16 % de ses dépenses à ce poste
budgétaire pour magny les hameaux la
somme atteint plus de 230 mille euros